okay Chad is white this time so I'll
flip the board we're looking From chat's
perspective
good luck everyone
wow a lot of E4 players
one A4 player
E4 it is
so again if you're just joining I hope
this is self-explanatory
I'm playing against the entire twitch
chat
you can vote for a move by simply typing
the move in notation or as notation in
chat
34 votes for E4
I'm actually a little bit conflicted
here like I want to give chat the option
to play ponziani
but I also
want to play the Stafford Gambit
uh let's play the Stafford gamut
some people say no Saturn
we can always play another game
I'm super curious so like what what the
what is uh like
the overall consensus against the
Stafford
are people gonna even allow this to ever
I'm seeing a lot of Knight takes e5s
which is good
do I pre-move this
I can pre-move this
okay Stafford Gabba time
how many people have watched my
my refutation video
see a lot of videos I I mentioned
refutation
I mean there's a lot of refutations of
the staff here
the engine already gives what like plus
two for white
okay I do see a lot of wait all moves
banned wait what
what does this mean
all moves banned
was this from earlier or
I understand that
anyway uh Stafford Gambit time
oh this will be fun
oh no my ALT accounts oh do people have
alt accounts
trying to rig the vote
it is fascinating just to see the
variety of different options that people
want to play here
de3 all right let's play Bishop C5
I really don't want to give any help
like sometimes when I'm playing a
singular person I'll draw arrows to show
the different options for whites
I guess here I could show what people
are
are wanting to play I See Bishop G5
Bishop E2 Bishop E3 H3 King E2
oh there's no votes for King YouTube One
vote for queen E2
all right I'll play H5
one vote for music question mark
I'm not playing any music right now this
might go on YouTube so I don't want to
deal with any potential of copyright
issues
if you want music you can open a new tab
all right this is interesting
H3
so White's preventing Knight G4
so let's play this move
well I need the checkmates
oh some people are disappointed that C3
wasn't played first
yeah there's some early nuances
a lot of people saying Bishop E3 but
that loses a pawn
oh
jpp says hi YouTube hi jpp
if you're watching in the future on
YouTube say hi to jpp
I have a vague memory of like playing a
very similar line
against twitch chat
years ago
is one of my most viewed YouTube videos
I like the vote for F4 illegal move
all right good luck everyone
be careful
I have ideas
this probably isn't too much of a
a hint
oh maybe I'm helping some people
[Music]
already see
one person blundering checkmate
I wonder what happens if you like type a
move and then decide to type another
move
yeah this is a the fishing pole idea
I've sacked a a knight
to open the file
be careful
[Music]
to be very careful wow E5 E5 is actually
a really clever move
because if I take the pawn
I lose my queen I think yeah because
Bishop F2 doesn't lead to anything
so
it's an interesting fight now
I'm just trying to exert as much
pressure as possible
tension between the Pawns
Bishop also playing a role
okay I think I know which move is coming
overwhelming majority of voting for
upon G4
one person voting for A3
all right so cha has officially One
Connect Four
I will take
oh no my Bishop
oh no
someone called ambulance
[Music]
I'm disappointed no one's saying do you
take C5
oh one person says D takes C5 okay
call an ambulance for that one person
so G3
yeah the sad thing is Queen takes G3
isn't mating because the F Pawn is no
longer pinned
and now it's a question what to do
I could play Bishop
Bishop G4
Bishop G4 looks interesting
H2 looks interesting
I'm gonna take my time here
uh so many choices
so much fun to be had I could also just
be normal and move back
what to do
I like the prospect of this
and developing with Tempo preparing this
attacking the queen
I see a lot of people blundering
this is this might be close actually
yeah so Queenie one
Queenie one I'll admit I initially
thought is a blunder but it's maybe
still a little bit tricky
although it probably is a blunder like I
think F3 was necessary
because now each two
and this H Pawn
it's moving up in the world
I guess moving down in the world
depending on your perspective
very soon it might no longer be a pawn
hey no resigning just yet
if you type resign you might get banned
also yeah White's still alive here
where's my checkmates
check there
it's really close
I want to check like this
that doesn't work
um
there's only one way to find out right
you could offer me a draw
I'm also looking at this move
which maybe doesn't lead to Checkmate
but it does look good
there's also this move or this move
so I have choices
and choices choices
I think I'll play Queen H7
a very Nifty move
oh no my Bishop yell again
someone called ambulance
I miss Maiden won
I think I considered the checks
we'll analyze afterwards don't worry
I am threatening made in Moana
some people are allowing it
the majority of people allowing it 14
votes
I think it was the point of no return
though
GG
okay
I guess I need to give a lesson on how
to
actually beat the Stafford
that was fun
at least fun for myself I'm not sure if
that was fun for
all the victims here